she had shed tears in court but outside
Olivia's mother Cheryl was composed in a
tribute to her murdered daughter it was
the life of Our Lives a sassy chatty
Gale who never ran out of energy
she was a character she was my baby and
she has amazing qualities and knew what
she wanted in life
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us
all I promise for their future so
cruelly taken away
Olivia's killer Thomas Cashman was given
life with a minimum sentence of 42 years
before any chance of parole by then
he'll be 76. we welcome the sentence
given but what I can say is that my
family and I have already started our
life sentence having to spend the rest
of our lives without Olivia
Cashman was chasing and shooting another
criminal Joseph knee when the fleeing
victim ran into the Corbell house
Cashman kept firing and hit Olivia as
children do Olivia was coming downstairs
to seek reassurance
Cheryl Corbell should have been able to
give that reassurance and to tuck Olivia
back into bed
what's happened instead was chilling and
strikes fear not only into the immediate
Community but also into the minds of
other children and their parents
shooting into a family home with no
regard for who may be caught in the
crossfire is obviously a very
significant aggravating factor which
must be reflected in the minimum term
Olivia's teenage Sister Chloe read a
personal statement to the court she said
I grieve for what we will never get to
do together I miss sharing my bedroom
with her and hearing her talk all of the
time all the things we should be doing
or would be doing as she got older
confiding in one another shopping
together laughing and making memories
Cashman didn't come into court to hear
his sentence his lawyer said he was
aware that after his conviction last
week Crown prosecutors were overheard
singing the song We Are the Champions
Cashman was concerned the case was
turning into a circus Olivia's Father
John Pratt told the court he had to
leave Liverpool he couldn't cope with
well-meaning people asking him about his
daughter Olivia Pratt Corbell died a
scared nine-year-old and we hope Cashman
is haunted by this knowledge for the
rest of his life
police said they hoped cashman's long
sentence would act as a deterrent to
anyone thinking of picking up a gun and
putting communities at risk Martin brunt
Sky News Manchester Crown Court